>> RECENT STUDIES SHOW SOCIAL
MEDIA IS MAKING YOUNG PEOPLE
UNHAPPY AND INSECURE ABOUT THEIR
LIVES.
HERE TO TALK IS LIFESTYLE
INFLUENCER.
>> SO, DAN, YOU'RE SUPER RICH
AND SHOW OFF YOUR CRAZY LIFE ON
INSTAGRAM, RIGHT?
>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S ON BASICALLY LIFE, STRAIGHT
UP.
LIFE.
PARTY'S ON.
BABES EVERYWHERE, SNOWBOARDING
WITH, LIKE, A BEZOOKAU.
MY LIFE IS INSANE.
>> YEAH, THAT'S COOL, MAP.
>> ASK ME HOW MANY GIRLS I'M
DATING RIGHT NOW.
>> HOW MANY GIRLS ARE YOU?
>> 940.
>> OKAY, COOL, MAN.
>> IT IS COOL, I AGREE.
OVER 900 GIRLS, I GOT THE NEW
BOOK.
WHY IS WRITING SO EASY?
YOU JUST HAVE TO PASS IT OUT.
>> YOU'RE WRITING A BOOK?
>> YEAH, MAN.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE HEMMINGWAY BUT
FOR GUYS.
>> WRITING ABOUT MY STRUGGLES
WITH SHIRTS.
>> BLOWING CROWDS AND CHANGING
THE WORLD THROUGH POSITIVITY.
IT'S CALLED AS BOOK.
>> THAT'S GOOD FOR YOU.
HOW DO YOU STAY SO DOWN TO
EARTH?
>> LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY.
YOU KNOW THE ANCIENT STORY A OF
THE FARMER AND THE CROW?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK I DO.
>> FARMER HAS THREE DOGS.
FARMER SAYS NO.
SECOND FARMER GOES YES, I SAW A
CROW.
DADDY SAYS NAAA.
THEN TO AN OLD MADE AND THE
FIRST GIRL -- UM.
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER.
>> HEY, YOU ALL RIGHT, MAN?
>> YEAH, THE POINT OF THE STORY
IS, LIKE, EVERYTHING IS JUST
INSANE.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S IT?
>> I THINK SO.
>> NO.
>> MY LIFE'S CRAZY.
>> I'M MICHAEL CHE.
>> I'M COLIN JOST.
GOODNIGHT.